shocking new docu-series
coming out of a e
about hugh hefner
the playboy you know the man who lived
a totally hedonistic existence for his
entire life
had a harem of women
whom he regularly
slept with all of them at the same time
many many times per week turns out this
is pretty shocking
he was kind of a bad guy
did you stop the presses
extra extra read all about it it turns
out that hugh hefner who was lauded by
the culture for many decades
half
turns out he was kind of a bad guy
in this docu-series they
lift the lid on the dark underbelly of
playboy
turns out if you just live with a bunch
of prostitutes for many decades and do a
bunch of drugs and abuse everybody and
just pursue your own pleasure
that might be kind of dark there might
be an it's not an underbell it's an
overbelly every anyone with two brain
cells to rub together knew this except
that playboy
and the popular culture generally
presented this very nice funny
cartoonish image of playboy the reality
was not quite like that one of the
playboy ladies who ran one of the
divisions
said it was cult-like the women had been
groomed and led to believe they were
part of this family heff really did
believe he owned these women we had
playmates that overdosed that committed
suicide
and many documentary participants said
that hefner's insatiable appetites led
to desensitization which led him to
demand stranger and stranger sexual
activities
this led him to watch snuff films films
in which people were
being killed and allegedly forcing
others to engage in sex acts with
animals or doing so himself one former
playmate said
he scared me in the end you couldn't
satisfy him he wanted more and more and
more
some people are saying well it's really
convenient that now that hef is dead all
these women are saying this stuff they
were happy to take paychecks for many
years they were happy to live this
lifestyle for many years
but now that he's dead they're coming
after him i don't believe any of it no
look obviously the women made terrible
decisions
but that doesn't let hefner off the hook
of course he did this creepy stuff
he didn't even really hide it did he
the culture just decided to
[Music]
laugh about it the culture just decided
to admire it
the reason i mentioned the story is not
to stomp on the grave of hugh hefner
who is i'm sure looking up at this uh at
this show right now in dismay
you hope he's not you hope he had some
kind of repentance but he didn't really
show it did he what these playmates are
describing is that things just got worse
and worse and worse and this is an
important lesson
for
conservatives as we look at the cult how
do you make a better culture we have a
pretty crappy culture right now how do
you make a better culture
you can't have a better culture
without
having people do better things and you
can't have people do better things
namely vice instead of virtue without
having inducements and incentives to
those better things and some of those
might be through private enterprise and
some of those might be through the
government and some is culture and some
is politics but as we've been describing
the two are kind of hard to separate
it's kind of hard to see the difference
sometimes between public and private
particularly since in recent years the
form of government we have is has used
is called the euphemistic public-private
partnership that's what you hear a lot
of liberals we need public-private
partnerships mussolini had public
private partnerships
we have an idea here that we that when
you engage in some vice
and engage in sin
and you live a hedonistic lifestyle for
a little bit it just blows off steam
that'll actually make society more
stable if you permit lots of vice and
sin and terrible stuff that's going to
make society more stable because people
aren't going to be so repressed
that's not how it works
virtue and vice actually are habits
the more vice you commit
the more vicious it's going to get
the more virtue you practice the more
virtuous you are going to get
you're never going to be perfect
you're probably not going to be totally
depraved and destroyed and hideous
you're gonna be totally evil and you're
not gonna be totally wonderfully perfect
and holy probably
but the more you practice one the more
you're gonna get the more you practice
the other the more you're gonna get
that's true on the individual level and
it's true for society
hold up stop don't put down the mouse do
people still use
mouse probably not
don't go anywhere ring that bell
subscribe
you will get the notifications for this
show if you don't get the notifications
then you should definitely head over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you